At the start of Game of Thrones, Arya Stark
is a rebellious tomboy.
She doesn’t want to be a noble lady like
society expects of her – she wants adventure
and freedom.
Arya loves her brother Jon – he understands
what it’s like to not fit in.
Jon gives Arya a sword called Needle.
Arya sees that the world is unfair – because
of Cersei’s cruelty and Joffrey’s lies,
Arya loses her wolf Nymeria, and her friend
Mycah is killed.
So Arya starts to hate her enemies . Syrio
Forel teaches Arya to fight – and says the
only god is death . When war begins with the
Lannisters, Arya has to leave Syrio for dead.
And when a stableboy grabs Arya, she stabs
him – Arya’s first kill is this poor dumb
kid.
Arya lives rough in King’s Landing for a
while, then sees the execution of her father
Ned.
Yoren takes her north, and for her safety,
Arya pretends to be a boy called Arry . So
in Season 1, Arya is separated from her family
and her identity, and moves towards violence
and death.
In Season 2, Arya makes friends with Gendry,
and Lommy and Hot Pie, but she struggles with
trauma from the loss and death she’s seen.
Her way of coping is to repeat a list of the
people she wants to kill . Yoren’s group
is attacked by Lannisters – a soldier called
Polliver kills Lommy and takes Needle . Arya’s
imprisoned at Harrenhal – where she suffers,
and sees innocent people tortured and killed.
She’s made to serve Tywin Lannister , the
man who’s waging a war against her family.
So Arya has to hide her identity, and use
her wits to survive.
A Faceless Man called Jaqen H’ghar kills
people for Arya , giving her a taste of power
and vengeance.
With Jaqen’s help, Arya Gendry and Hot Pie
escape Harrenhal.
Jaqen offers to train Arya in Braavos , but
she wants to stay and find her family . Jaqen
leaves Arya with a coin, and the words “Valar
Morghulis” – all men must die.
So Harrenhal hardens Arya, teaching her to
use violence and cunning to survive.
In Season 3, Arya Gendry and Hot Pie are captured
by the Brotherhood Without Banners.
The Brotherhood also captures the Hound, and
Arya wants him dead, because the Hound killed
Mycah.
But the Hound wins his trial and goes free
– so again Arya finds no justice in the
world.
Arya wants a “family” of people she can
rely on, but Hot Pie and Gendry both leave
her, so Arya feels abandoned and alone.
Arya learns to use a bow better, which might
come in handy.
And Melisandre visits, saying that she’ll
meet Arya again . But then the Brotherhood
betrays Gendry, and they fail to take Arya
home.
So Arya gets sick of their bullshit and runs
away – but then she’s captured by the
Hound.
The Hound takes Arya to the Twins, and for
a moment, Arya dares to hope that she’ll
see her family again – but they arrive in
time for the Red Wedding, where Arya’s mother
and brother are murdered.
Arya’s hopes are crushed again, and all
she can do is kill some Freys in vengeance
– she uses Jaqen’s coin and says “Valar
Morghulis” . So in Season 3, Arya learns
that she can’t rely on anyone – friends
will just leave her, family will die, and
there’s no justice, unless she kills her
enemies herself .
In Season 4, Arya journeys through the war-torn
riverlands with the Hound, who leads her deeper
into violence and cynicism.
They fight some Lannisters, and Arya kills
Polliver – the first name off her list.
She avenges Lommy, retrieves Needle, and gets
her own horse to ride.
This is like the first good thing that happens
to Arya in three seasons, and she achieves
it by killing.
When a kind farmer offers them food and a
job, the Hound mugs the farmer.
Arya is furious, but the Hound teaches that
this just “the way things are” – the
weak die, and the strong survive . He says
hate is a good motivation to keep someone
going . On one level, Arya hates the Hound
for being so brutal and callous . But the
Hound is also the only person who understands
Arya.
The Hound feels betrayed by his family, abandoned
and alone , with only hate and violence to
hide his hurt – and that’s just how Arya
feels . So Arya and the Hound care for each
other when no one else does.
Arya meets Brienne, and she likes her – identifies
with another misfit female warrior.
But the Hound gets suspicious, and they end
up fighting – leaving the Hound near death.
The Hound asks Arya to mercy kill him , but
Arya refuses.
She tells herself that she wants the Hound
to suffer.
But deep down, Arya just doesn’t want to
kill her only friend . With most of her family
dead, and with nowhere to go , Arya uses Jaqen’s
coin to sail to Braavos.
Maybe here she can find peace, happiness and
family.
But nope, she joins a death cult.
In Season 5, Arya joins the Faceless Men – a
cult of assassins who worship death . To truly
join them, Arya must become “No one” – to
give up her identity, all her hopes, loves
and hates.
So Arya throws away the things that make her
Arya, except she secretly keeps Needle.
This sword represents her family, Winterfell,
Jon – so deep down, Arya remains a Stark.
Arya works in the House of Black and White
– she sweeps, cleans corpses, and gives
the gift of death to a suffering child.
She contends with the waif, a rival Faceless
Man who doesn’t believe that Arya is no
one . Arya takes on the identity of Lanna
, and spies around Braavos.
Jaqen orders her to kill her first target,
the “thin man” . But instead, Arya goes
after Meryn Trant, the Kingsguard who killed
Syrio.
She follows Meryn to a brothel, uses a Faceless
disguise, and brutally kills him – another
name off her list.
But the Faceless are mad, because Arya not
only killed the wrong person, but she did
it for her personal revenge.
When the Faceless Men are meant to be no one,
giving death anonymously as a religious gift.
So the man who Arya thinks is Jaqen kills
himself, but then another Man wears Jaqen’s
face.
Because there is no Jaqen, he’s just a false
identity worn by the Faceless Men.
So in the most confusing way possible, Arya
loses another “friend” . And because Arya
wore a face before she was allowed, Arya is
made blind . Season 5 plunges Arya into darkness.
In Season 6, Arya lives as a blind beggar
in Braavos.
The waif beats her with a stick, teaching
her to fight blind – and trying to break
her psychologically, to make her admit she’s
not no one . But Arya persists.
She gets a training montage, and fights with
sticks, until she can finally hold off the
waif, and Jaqen gives her sight back.
Jaqen orders Arya to kill an actress called
Lady Crane, and warns this is Arya’s last
chance to join the Faceless.
Arya watches Crane act in a play about Westeros
– and relives the execution of her father.
But she’s also moved by Cersei’s grief,
as played by Lady Crane.
Arya likes Crane, so she refuses to kill her.
Which means she’s used up her last chance
with the Faceless Men . Arya takes back Needle,
gets a haircut, and books a ship home.
But then she’s attacked by the waif, and
almost dies.
She’s saved by Lady Crane – Arya’s mercy
saves her own life.
For the first time in a long time, Arya rests
and feels safe with a friend who cares for
her, but then the waif kills Crane – another
dead friend.
Arya lures the waif to a dark room, and uses
her blind training to kill her.
She confronts Jaqen, and says she’s not
no one – she’s Arya Stark of Winterfell,
and she’s going home . So in Season 6, Arya
learns the Faceless skills of deception and
disguise, but she also returns to her identity
as Arya, and she goes back to Westeros.
Arya kills Walder Frey, and bakes his sons
into a pie.
And in Season 7, Arya disguises herself with
Walder’s face, and poisons a room full of
Freys – finally avenging the Red Wedding
. But then she meets some Lannister soldiers,
and learns that not all of her enemies are
evil – some of them are Ed Sheeran.
Arya meets her old friend Hot Pie, and they
don’t quite reconnect.
Arya’s unable to describe what she’s been
through . Her experiences have changed her.
She runs into her direwolf Nymeria, and asks
the wolf to come with her, but she doesn’t
. Cause Nymeria has changed, become wild and
independent – she isn’t the pet she was
before, just like Arya isn’t the girl she
was before.
Arya returns to Winterfell, and it’s changed
too.
Sansa has become Lady Stark , in charge of
the castle, and Bran has become a psychic
weirdo.
Arya gets a Valyrian steel dagger, and makes
friends with Brienne.
But Sansa is disturbed that her sister is
now a killer . And Arya accuses Sansa of undermining
Jon for her own political power.
All the sisters’ childhood resentments return,
and Littlefinger works to divide them further
– it gets to the point where Arya threatens
to kill Sansa . But in the finale, the sisters
finally unite, and bring Littlefinger to justice.
They learn to respect one another, and bond
over their Stark identities . So in Season
7, we see how the experiences that made Arya
a powerful killer have also alienated her
from her friends and family.
If she continues her path of vengeance, will
Arya lose her humanity?
What’ll happen to Arya in the final season
of Thrones?
There’ll be more reunions – Arya will
finally see Jon again . She’ll likely reunite
with Gendry, and there could be a romance
there – Gendry likes to call Arya “my
lady” . Arya will meet Daenerys, and she’ll
probably like her – Arya has said that she
admires dragon queens , maybe she’ll get
a dragon ride.
Reunions with the Hound and Melisandre and
Beric will be complicated, cause they were
all on Arya’s death list for a while . Will
Arya still hold these grudges?
There might not be time for that drama.
Cause in the Season 8 trailer, the dead attack
Winterfell, and Arya fights for the living.
With her Valyrian dagger, and obsidian weapons,
she might kill a white walker or two.
Maybe her ultimate test as an assassin could
be trying to kill the Night King . Bran gave
her that dagger for a reason.
But Arya will wanna finish her death list,
and the last two names are the Mountain and
Queen Cersei . The Hound once said that he
and Arya could kill the Mountain together
. Maybe the Hound will be wounded in this
fight, and Arya will finally have to mercy-kill
her friend . But will Arya kill Cersei?
Arya was sympathetic when she saw Cersei played
by Lady Crane.
Arya relates to Cersei’s feelings of grief
and anger . So maybe Arya will show Cersei
mercy, just like she spared Crane . Arya’s
actress, Maisie Williams, said she hopes Arya
will let go of anger and revenge, to find
peace and happiness . Maybe Arya can finally
get the family she’s always wanted.
Like, she wouldn’t marry a lord and have
fifteen kids – that’s not her.
But maybe she could have home at Winterfell
as queensguard for Sansa, or for Jon or Daenerys.
Or maybe she’ll go off on her own as an
adventurer, and see what’s west of Westeros
. She could sail into the sunset like Frodo
in Lord of the Rings – a sad farewell to
a hero who was never quite whole after what
they’d been through.
Or maybe Arya will only find peace in death.
Her whole story is soaked in blood and loss
and trauma.
Maybe when winter comes, the lone wolf will
die alone.
In the Game of Thrones books, Arya is warg
like Bran – she can enter the mind of Nymeria.
So there are cool theories about Arya dying
but living on in her wolf, running with her
pack.
The books have a lot more magic and prophecy
than the show.
Everything's darker and deeper and more complex.
If you wanna check out the books, you can
get one on audiobook for free today by signing
up for a trial at audible.com/asx.
Audible has the whole Game of Thrones series,
including the worldbook, short stories, and
the new history book, Fire and Blood.
Members can choose a free book each month,
and if you cancel, you keep the books.
You can listen to audiobooks while you drive,
or gym, or while you cross the Narrow Sea.
Thanks for watching.
Please like and subscribe, and comment below
which character we should recap next.
We’ll be doing weekly livestreams right
after each episode of Thrones Season 8.
Thanks to the Patrons, including Ashley Napoli,
Sarah Parker-Shemilt, Lisa Vol, Brian Meldrum,
Mistyspecs, Will Geffen, Hung Nguyen, Kristy
Rasmussen-Vincent, Wright Cheung, Colin Pocsik,
and Nope.
Cheers.